hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to especially when
you're going this fast my hands
practically shaking right now
I can do this someone that believes in
me a lot of people may not God actually
is coming [ __ ] that's how hard it is
that's how unforgiving this is that is
how obscenely difficult this is open the
door before I can see it's because it's
so easy to miss your target when I'm
playing this you know god damn it
God do you knew such a good attempt God
it's there's no way to recover from this
years it's done
good attempt why did I open the door so
Freddie's not in killing position until
right about now okay this is a great
start beginning
what am I gonna do with my life no such
a good attempt to I was doing so good
they're generally nice oh my god my
hands cramping up I've been playing this
all damn day
so whoo all right here we go more time I
spend on four bars I just [ __ ] myself
cuz I screwed up my pattern that's what
it does
Freddy Freddy
oh dang Oh short version this time also
it's entirely luck if you won't connect
because it's up to Freddy doing this
long thing and he may not do as long
[Music]
oh so [ __ ] I [ __ ] up everything I
[ __ ] up
20 20 20 but I think I'm to the point
where I can predictably get there so
here we go I kind of freaking work ok
it's 5 a.m. now foxy come on
okay there's a chance there's a chance
[Music]
damn it those early
damnit he didn't even finish his song
you really wants me to not win
[Music]
I don't even think if if if
all right now I don't think it even if
Freddie tells his longest wind-up which
i think is a maximum of fifty seconds
[Music]
what am I doing with my life I'm already
cocking it up so bad I [ __ ] that up
[ __ ] and you did very much to get
through to this game oh no no no I just
screwed myself tonight oh god don't do
that Dad [ __ ] that [ __ ] all that I
cannot make mistakes like that I'm
already making mistakes early but I
think it's okay I didn't oh god you have
a course on iCarly he's gonna do is
quick one after being perfect for so
long it's chance it's flipping chance
concern 2 a.m. and I'm above Oh what did
I okay that's the pattern sorry that's
good Foxy's little entrance there yep
you're doing your shorts on that's good
that's exactly what I wanted Oh
[ __ ] you so hard [ __ ] god damn it it's
seven [ __ ] [ __ ] but he really stepped
up Margot there's a [ __ ] stupidest
yep yep that's for me kill me already so
I can move on Foxy's out which is dumb
because hate this game I hate it I hate
it a lot I hate a lot I hate this game
alott famous hate your hate god dammit
god dammit [ __ ] [ __ ]
once she just Lloyd her back in pirate
Cove
[ __ ] [ __ ]
damn it damn it damn it damn it damn it
damn it [ __ ] me so that's my land I [ __ ]
I hate everything I'm so frustrated
right now Freddie if Freddie would have
taken the time then on one of my
previous playthroughs I would have won I
would have won it's totally up to luck
and I hate luck I hate random chance
I hate when skill doesn't mean
everything and that kills me but either
way I am officially done I can't do it
anymore
I cannot I'm throwing in the towel it's
insanity it's insanity insanity to even
try
it's why I'm gonna do it one more time
god damn it
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
while a string quartet are back disaster
got playing us
Oh sousaphone man